Bonjour!
Pour ce deuxième épisode de Gentes Dames
Badass je vais vous présenter Christine de
Pizan, une femme de lettres qui a vécu entre
le XIVe et le XVe siècle.
Elle naît en 1365 à Venise mais déménage
en France à l'âge de quatre ans car son
père est nommé médecin et astrologue du
roi Charles V.
J'aime les astrologues.
A 15 ans elle épouse Etienne de Castel, qui
est notaire et secrétaire du roi Charles
VI.
Celui qui vent après Charles V.
Ensemble ils ont trois enfants, dont un fils
qui meurt en bas âge, et probablement d'autres
enfants morts nés puisqu'elle déclare être
souvent enceinte.
Enfin, ils sont plutôt heureux mais ça ne
dure que quelques années: en 1387 son père
meurt, puis son mari en 1390.
A 25 ans elle doit donc gérer la famille
toute seule, ses enfants, sa mère et sa nièce,
ce qui coûte cher.
Elle commence par vendre certaines terres
qui avaient appartenu à son père, mais ça
ne suffit pas, d'autant que certaines personnes
lui font des procès pour des questions de
rente foncière.
Elle doit bien gagner de l'argent: elle
se lance donc dans l'écriture, à partir
de 1399.
D'abord elle écrit des poèmes, des ballades,
puis des livres en prose lorsque sa notoriété
commence à croître.
Ses premiers livres sont en partie autobiographiques,
puisqu'elle y parle de la perte de son mari
et de ses difficultés à faire vivre la famille.
Ensuite, elle change de ton et produit des
écrits plus engagés sur la société française
et les problèmes de son temps.
Elle s'instruit seule, puisqu'elle n'a pas
eu accès à l'école, et tente de dresser
le portrait d'un couple royal exemplaire dans
plusieurs de ses livres.
Selon elle le bon roi doit être noble de
cœur, respecter les codes de la chevalerie
et avoir acquis la sagesse par l’étude
et les conseils de ses proches, tandis que
la bonne reine doit être vertueuse, et est
chargée de faire respecter la paix et l’amour
dans la société.
Ses livres sont lus par les personnages les
plus importants du royaume, puisque Philippe
le Hardi lui commande le Livre des fais et
bonnes meurs du sage roy Charles V en 1405.
Elle dédie d'autres ouvrages à Louis XI,
et rédige aussi un Livre des fais d'armes
et de chevalerie destiné à la noblesse où
elle présente les bonnes manières de mener
la guerre.
Un traité de guerre écrit par une femme
au XVe siècle, je trouve ça pas mal.
Elle y parle de la manière dont les rois
doivent mener une bataille, elle raconte l'histoire
de grands chefs de guerre et fait même du
droit d'armes.
Sa carrière prend fin après le Livre de
Paix, écrit vers 1412.
En 1418 Paris est envahie par les bourguignons,
et elle part alors finir ses jours au prieuré
de Saint-Louis de Poissy où elle meurt vers
1430.
Christine de Pizan a donc été la première
femme de lettres à vivre de sa plume, et
ça n'a pas toujours été une situation facile.
Dès le début du XVe siècle, malgré sa
notoriété, elle subit les critiques de quelques
auteurs, surtout par rapport au fait que c'est
une femme.
Cette exception lui garantit une forte notoriété
pendant un siècle, puisqu'elle est rééditée
jusque 1489, mais ensuite elle tombe dans
l'oubli.
Elle est de nouveau étudiée au XIXe siècle,
où on considère alors qu'elle critiquait
la monarchie française dans ses écrits,
ce qui n'est pas vraiment le cas: Christine
de Pizan critiquait surtout le règne de Charles
VI, mais pensait tout de même que la monarchie
était le meilleur des régimes et que le
peuple était de toute façon ignorant et
manipulable.
Pas très Charlie donc.
Au début du XXe siècle elle est considérée
comme une compilatrice: elle lisait des
livres, et s'appropriait les connaissances
qu'elle y trouvait dans ses écrits.
Un peu comme moi dans cette vidéo puisque
j'ai largement bénéficié du mémoire d'un
pote pour écrire cet épisode, et je l'en
remercie!
Christine de Pizan devient un symbole féministe
dans la 2e moitié du XXe siècle.
Même si elle était effectivement la première
femme de lettres en France à vivre de ce
qu'elle écrivait, il faut quand même éviter
les anachronismes: dans ses écrits, Christine
de Pizan réaffirmait la place des femmes
dans la société mais ne cherchait pas à
transformer l'ordre établi.
Ça, c'est Françoise Autrand qui l'a dit.
Si vous voulez aller plus loin...
Il n'empêche qu'elle était une autrice moderne
pour l'époque puisqu'elle abordait des sujets
tels que la guerre, la politique, etc.
Et rien que pour ça, je trouve qu'elle mérite
sa place parmi les gentes dames badass.
Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode et on
se retrouve dans deux semaines pour une femme
qui avait totalement sa place dans la game
politique du XVIe siècle.